[음악]
네. 네, 안녕하세요. 빌사남입니다.
어, 제가 오늘은 BSN의 목표라든지
뭐 앞으로 진행하는 거에 대해서 좀
얘기해 보려고 하는데 뭐 저는 이제
경영자이기도 하고 앞으로의 방향에
따라서 회사의 뭔가 규모라든지 이런게
완전 달라지기 때문에 어, 좀 이렇게
앞으로 뭘 할지를 되게 고민을 많이
하는데 어, 최근에 좀 고민 많이
했던 거는 일단 해외 진출이 제일 첫
번째인 거 같아요. 뉴욕도 가고
일본도 가고 두바이도 가고 하긴
했지만 제가 봤을 때 당장 BSN을
진출해서 할 수 있는 나라는 저는
두바이라고 생각을 해서 두바이의
법인을 설립하려고 지금 좀 알아보고
있고 시간이 좀 많이 걸리긴 하겠지만
첫 번째로는 두바이에 진출하지 않을까
이렇게 생각을 합니다. 이런 것도
했었어요. 뭐 BSN이 이제 중동
국가 진출하는 내용을 토대로 뭔가
넷플릭스 제자를 하면 좋을 것
같다라고 해서 어 넷플릭스 쪽에 이제
메일을 보냈는데 어 거의 한 달 동안
다 미습니다. 아, 물론 뭐 보낸
거에 의미가 있으니까 계속 도전해 볼
거고 어, 넷플릭스가 워낙 이제 뭐
외국인들도 많이 보고 파급력도 되게
커 가지고 그런 넷플릭스를 제작하기
위해서 많이 노력하지 않을까
싶습니다. 그리고 그 이외에는 이제
여러 사업을 좀 준비하고 있는데
최근에 조금 이제 뭐 얘기하고 있는
거는 저희가 그 엔터테인먼트 회사를
설립을 했어요. 회사에 이렇게 빌드업
하면은 괜찮으신 분들이 되게
많거든요. 영상 편집이라든지 영상
기획이라든지 이분을 어떻게 브랜딩 해
가지고 할지를 되게 고민한 다음에 그
부동산 인플루언서 계약을 했습니다.
그래서 지금 한 두 명은 계약이 돼
있고 한 분은 이제 또 조만간에 할
생각이에요. 그래서 회사 내에 이렇게
부동산 인플루언서를 키우는 부동산
기획사 같은 거를 좀 준비를 하고
있습니다. 뭐 되게 여러 가지가
있는데 저는 일단은 시작하는게 제일
중요하긴 해 가지고 뭐 그거 말고 뭐
이렇게 공간을 채우는 사업이라든지
그다음에 시니어 관련된 사업이라든지
지금 두바이에서 최근에 이제 규제나
이런게 좀 많이 완화가 돼서
전체적으로 봤을 때는 이제 시장이
그쪽으로 가는게 맞기는 해 가지고 좀
그쪽 시장도 준비 중이고 그리고
자산운영서 제가 말씀드렸는데 작년에
면허가 나왔었거든요. 근데 원래 이제
부동산을 매입하려고 만들었는데 지금은
요즘에 이제 회사를 좀 많이 살하고
있습니다. 그래서 요즘 경기가 워낙
안 좋다 보니까 저렴하게 사 가지고
좀 이렇게 가치를 올리는 뭔가 그런
사업을 좀 많이 생각을 하고
있습니다. 네. 필도 지금 요즘에
이제 AI 시대 되면서 보통은 이제
매물 찾을 때 중계사님들도
매물이 너무 많다 보면 뭐 어떤
매물이 있는지도 잘 모르거든요.
AI에 이제 학습시키고 뭔가 이제
업데이트 해 놓으면 그 AI가 쉽게
찾아줄 수 있을 것 같아요. 그런
프로그램도 좀 뭔가 앞으로 개발해야
되지 않을까라고 해서 지금 준비
중이고 저는 그런 거 같아요.
그러니까 이제 예를 들어서 못을
박으려고 하는데 그 맨손으로 이렇게
박는게 아니라 기구를 잘 이용해서
어떻게 하면 중계사들이 효율성 있게
뭔가 업무를 할 수 있을까 뭐 이런
거를 생각을 많이 하고 있습니다.
기타로는 너무 많아요. 하고 싶은게
저는 사업에 있어서 어찌 됐든 사람
중심이잖아요. 그래서 잘할 사람들을
좀 찾고 있습니다. 예를 들어서 뭐이
시니어 사업을 잘할 사람을 찾아서 그
사람한테 위임을 하고 그 사람이 잘
운영을 할 수 있게끔 만들어 주는게
이제 제 역할이고 안정적인 사업을
운영하는게 목표입니다. 그래서 한
가지에 너무 모든 걸 다 걸지 않고
좀 사업 다각화를 하는게 제 목표기
때문에 BSN이 앞으로 신규 사업하는
거 뭐 이런 것들도 좀 기대해 주시면
좋을 거 같고 어쨌든 제가 지금
젊으니까 저는 되게 여러 가지 사업
많이 하고 싶고 국내뿐만 아니라
해외에도 좀 많이 알리고 싶은 어
그런 아주 큰 목표가 있습니다.
그리고 뭐 개인적으로는 어 제가 뭐
많이 탔어요.
아주 밖에 너무 많이 돌아다녀 가지고
제가 뭐 아들이 두 명 있는데 어
아들이랑 밖에서 워낙 뭐 요즘에
활동을 많이 해 가지고 뭐 얼마 전엔
저기 개벌가 가지고 막 어 밖에서
놀아 주느라고 지금 선크림 발라도
지금 엄청 탔는데 좀 그렇게 최대한
가족들이랑 많이 보내려고 하고 있고
그리고 뭐 운동도 요즘 좀 열심히
합니다. 그래서 PT도 하고 있고
그다음에 필라테스도 하고 있는데 근데
많은 분들이 필라테스 왜 하는데 저는
필라테스를 매우 강추합니다. 어
남성들이 해야 되는 운동이고
필라테스라는 이름도 남성분
이름이에요. 그래서 그 정도로
남성분한테 굉장히 좀 도움이 되는
그런 운동이라고 저는 생각을 합니다.
그래서 필라테스도 그래도 좀
정기적으로 하고 있고 그다음에
주말에는 보통 테니스 많이 있어요.
베니스 원래 이제 골프를 막 배우다가
이게 시간이 워낙 오래 걸리고 만약에
나중에 필드 가더라도 뭐 시간이 어
너무 많이 이제 소유가 되기 때문에
좀 짧은게 뭐가 있을까 생각하다가
주변에 이제 텐 치는 거 보고 쳤는데
어 저는 되게 만족해 가지고 사실
건강 관리는 하고 싶은 거 오래하고
싶어 가지고 건강하고 있고 어찌됐든
제가 건강해야 되니까 어이 모든게 다
이제 에너지가 필요하다 보니까 어떻게
하면 체력을 키울 수 있을까를 좀
많이 생각하는 거 같습니다. 그래서
여러분들 앞으로 좀 기대해 주시면
좋을 거 같고 어 오늘 영상 여기까지
하겠습니다.
[음악]